e due edizioni the stories oggi nova
challenge intesa vi faccia forte una
challenge crimini ma non fare rumore
sale gioco però la facciamo con cocco
dentista se avete visto il nostro altro
che abbiamo come delitto abbiamo urlato
tantissima poi fatto farlo chiudere e
c'era un dentino dio come stai fermo più
non solo abbiamo il nostro classico
cocco dentista del dome con la bocca
enorme ma abbiamo mi un mini co.co
dentista questo ha i denti anche viso
allora uno alla volta avremo alla volta
dovremo premere un dente dei vari o
orologi sono dare dovremo premere
ammette dei vari cocco prima di quello
grande e poi quello piccolo è la
challenge chi fa più rumore perde quindi
poi alla fine del video dovesse votare
vi metterà un po infondante dovrete
votare chi ha fatto più rumore e drum
kit d'aria
secondo me già si sa chi vince però è
molto difficile riuscire a rimanere in
silenzio con questi 28 con queste due
macchine delle tortore allora siamo
pronti lascio un bel likes se volete
altre cose non fare rumore challenge la
scorpacciata 0 a tutti 10mila ai comuni
abbiamo deciso di rifarsi un altro c'è
anche questo video le 10 mian ex di fare
un'altra ancora consigliateci oppure le
vostre idee miei commenti prende di
focale è
[Musica]
aia mi hanno molto tutti e due
2 a testa
[Musica]
no
[Applauso]
[Musica]
no
ma per il resto va malissimo perché hai
detto anche sopra fa malissimo questo
era quello che è divertente ma anche
tressanti avuto tre bottoni
contemporaneamente va bene se non
altrettanto
di questi lasciate città e santu del
momento che mi ha fatto divertire di più
così noi lo riguarderemo quattro gatti
linee su cui cliccare per vedere i
nostri altri video
i nostri video divertenti le nostre
altre challenge cliccate su quella di
preferire leoni